parlons-en de cette vague de froid parce
qu'il y en a qui ont tendance parfois se
réchauffer avec des systèmes d'appoint
donc faut rappeler qu'il ya plusieurs
types d'appareils qui peuvent dégager du
monoxyde de carbone causer des
intoxications c'est un gars vous le
rappeler toxique invisible inodore avec
moi luc lefebvre toxicologue à la
direction de la santé publique de
montréal c'est le fait bonjour bonjour
toujours très sournois lé money ce
qu'est le monoxyde de carbone oui tout à
fait tout à fait on l'appelle le tueur
silencieux c'est un gaz qui a pas
d'odeur qui n'a pas de couleur et qui va
se présenter dans les domiciles
lorsqu'on a une source qui utilise un
carburant ou une fouille et tout
appareil qui vont brûler ces matériaux
vont générer du monoxyde de carbone si
le moindrement l'entretien n'a pas été
bien fait les concentrations vont
augmenter rapidement ils vont générer
des effets chez les personnes qui vont
être sournois donc les effets vont
commencer vont être très subtil mottet
d'étourdissement un peu nausées et plus
la durée de la concentration et
l'exposition vont augmenter les effets
vont vont s'amplifier pour amener
jusqu'à une perte de conscience et dans
les cas les plus tragiques jusqu'au
décès c'est pas une mortelle oui tout à
fait à vrai dire c'est un principe de
toxicologie donc tout dépend de la dose
aucun doute exposé si la dose est faible
ça peut prendre plusieurs bombes août en
vain que la concentration dans
l'organisme parce que le monoxyde de
carbone vient prendre la place de
l'oxygène au niveau de l'hémoglobine et
ça vient jouer sur le transport
d'oxygène dans tous les organes donc les
effets vont commencer tranquillement
mais si l'exposition et les fortes ça va
la vitesse kiki folle donc les effets
vont apparaître très rapidement et les
gens vont constater qu'ils sont très mal
en point et donc ils doivent avoir des
bons réflexes pour être capable de
sortir du domicile avant d'avoir des
effets très grave et qu'il ya une vague
de froid vous êtes sensible à ça vous
savez qu'il ya des gens qui vont prendre
des systèmes de chauffage d'appoint et
les rentrées dans leur maison oui hélas
qu'il ya des risques importants
oui quelles sont les mesures de sécurité
que vous voulez rappelé ce matin la
mesure la plus simple c'est lorsqu'on
utilise une source qui peut générer du
monoxyde de carbone on doit se doter
d'un détecteur de monoxyde de carbone
c'est comme les détecteurs de fumée mais
c'est directement pour évaluer la
concentration de monoxyde de carbone
c'est à par lots vient de simuler ce qui
se passe dans notre organisme
donc dès que l'appareil vous constatez
sur une période de temps qui est
variable
dès qu'elles vont constater qu'il y à un
niveau d'exposition qui pourrait menacer
la santé en dessous des seuils dangereux
elle va donner un signal à l'âme et les
gens vont savoir qu'un problème on doit
avoir sur la maison ça coûte trop cher
c'est un moyen efficace parce qu'il n'ya
pas vraiment d'autres moyens de le
détecter comme je le disais il n'y a pas
d'odeur il n'y a pas de couleur les gens
vont souvent percevoir les premiers
signes et symptômes en disant j'ai eu
une intoxication alimentaire qui
débutent ou un début de grippe par un
rhume donc et il n'a suffit pas
directement les faits à à la substance
comprend pas trop ce qu'on a
alors pour vous là c'est même pas une
question on doit avoir un détecteur oui
on doit avoir cet appareil là ça coûte
pas tellement cher rambo devenue une
cinquantaine de dollars on installe sur
la maison ça fonctionne tout le temps et
donc ils vont vous donner une alarme
vous êtes certain évidemment les mesures
de privation normal si vous avez un
système qui relie en cheminée faire
relire nettoyer votre cheminée les
systèmes d'entretien sont toujours
présents mais la police d'assurance
c'est le détecteur de monoxyde de
carbone parlez moi maintenant du
déneigement des voitures parce que là
aussi il faut faire attention quand il
ya quelqu'un à l'intérieur oui tout à
fait ça aussi c'est un phénomène
et ça c'est vraiment d intoxication ou
des décès on en a l'art de chaque
tempête de neige
oui lorsque des tempêtes de neige qui
sont importantes la vie qu ils vont se
retrouver souvent on va voir dans les
milieux urbains ou dans d'autres
endroits lorsque la neige s'accumule de
nos autos deviennent un peu comme des
aiguilles exactement est donc souvent
les gens
vont sortir à l'extérieur vont dire ben
j'ai déjà un jeune enfant ou une
personne qui est avec moi le reste repas
à l'extérieur donc on va déneiger une
porte la personne va prendre place dans
la voiture aux parlementaires on met la
ventilation maximum on veut que ça soit
confortable et le tuyau d'échappement
n'est pas dégagé la neige le monoxyde de
carbone qui est générée par le véhicule
est ce un véhicule ça génère des
concentrations en monoxyde de carbone
qui sont vraiment extrêmement important
et l'on en l'espace de quelques minutes
votre ventilation qui dans le véhicule
appelle l'art sous le véhicule
rendant à dans l'auto les concentrations
sont extrêmement importantes et on va
voir des personnes dans plusieurs cas
pathétique là où on a vu des
intoxications et des décès à l'espace
d'une dizaine de minutes le temps qu on
déneige de véhicules
la personne a perdu conscience est
décédé et ça on en a à chaque tempête de
neige
ils sont les recommandations faites
l'inversé de la logique normal de dire
mon parti ne partait jamais votre
véhicule tant qu'il n'est pas déneigée
assoyez-vous à l'intérieur c'est vous
les placez vos enfants dans le siège
d'appoint nouveaux entrants l'extérieur
mais ne partez pas le véhicule attendait
que la voiture soit complètement
déneigée et hirson à l'eau vous partez
vous allez à votre à la droite dégagé le
tuyau d'échappement se serait pas une
solution c'est une solution mais c'est
souvent pas totalement complet parce qu
on comprend que les systèmes
d'échappement ce n'est pas un système
qui est totalement étanche
donc même si une bonne partie qui sort à
l'arrière ban du moteur jusqu'à
l'extrémité du véhicule arrière mais il
ya du monoxyde de carbone qui
s'accumulent sous le véhicule donc tout
seul lorsqu'on parle d'art et puis ça se
concentrent directement à l'habitacle
c'est un tout petit endroit
les concentrations m'ont très vite et ce
à sa voix une vitesse folle donc dans
tous les cas qu'on en fait des
évaluations en l'espace de quelques
minutes les gens vont développer des
effets si on n'est pas attentif on
constate qu'effectivement la personne a
perdu conscience et dans plusieurs cas
il ya des déçus donc on change nos
habitudes complètement on déneige la
voiture merci beaucoup d'avoir été là ce
matin ça me fait plaisir